Continue working on your project or open the file named for-anim-paths if you need to catch up.
Earlier you learned how to add vehicles and characters to the scene.
These elements were mostly stationary even though the characters had some simple idle animations to them.
If you wanted to make the characters walk about or vehicles drive by, you need to use Animation Paths tools.
Initialize them to populate in the dock.
When you expand the Paths panel on the right, you get four options.
Dedicated paths are available for characters, bicycles, and vehicles, and a custom path can be used for other objects.
Mostly all these tools work the same way with slide variations.
We'll start with character paths but first, we'll make sure the right container is active.
In the scene graph, right-click the people container and set it current.
In the Path panel, click on Character Path.
The pen icon is automatically activated.
Draw a path by clicking a few points on the sidewalk or in front of the building.
Right-click to end the command.
You have options to adjust the density, and path width, sort the ethnicity and clothing, and reverse the motion.
Or stop the walk altogether and have them idle in place as if they were waiting in line.
Once you're done with one path, you can create another one by revisiting the Populate panel.
You can then create other paths for other groups of people.
You can adjust the path by relocating its placed points.
If you're having difficulty selecting a path in the viewport, you can also select it in the scene graph.
Similarly, you can create animation paths for vehicles.
Zoom back a bit to give yourself a wider view on the main street.
Make sure the appropriate container is active before you start though.
And then in the Populate panel, choose Paths, Vehicle Path.
Again, use the pen tool to draw a path down the middle of the road.
Here you can choose options such as the number of lanes, or in this case, a two-way road.
You can adjust the lane offset, vehicle density, and speed as well.
If you were to reduce the speed and get closer to a car, you'll see the wheels rotating properly.
You don't have to adjust anything to get the proper behavior.
Another nice touch is that if you were to use the time of day to switch to night time,
then car lights are automatically activated.
You can press G to disable the helper's visibility in the viewport.
The scene is coming together nicely.
In the last video, we'll bring a bit more life to it by adding vegetation, like grass, shrubs, and trees.